alors c'est vrai qu'il a il a pas l'air
super en forme a globalement mais est ce
qu'à peine raisons artistiques dans la
évidemment il vient juste de terminer un
film où il joue le rôle d'un professeur
d'université atteints du cancer et il
est en phase finale dans ce film ce
qu'il s'appelle richard sykes goodbye
arrête toi c'est le film sera d'ailleurs
il veut y sera très en forme d'ailleurs
au hellfest le 22 juin au le fait bien
qu à clisson crise a en loire atlantique
qui sera là le 22 avec son groupe
hollywood man par ailleurs avec lui ben
voilà ce qu'il connaisse qui mène une
vie très saine en plus aller jusqu'au
bout alors moi qui lis les quelques
canards américain qui me sont
accessibles au rayonnement national et
intérêts on peut les taux et les photos
les photos c'est clair que il moi pas
que de l'eau et qu'ils se couchent pas à
huit heures du soir ça c'est clair il
n'y avait pas que ces missiles ne la
prenez pas pour une imbécile bernard
godet qui qui qui garde toute la nuit ça
c'est très bien comme et quand je dis
bien vieilli prématurément alors quand
il fait des bêtises de son corps c'est
possible moi par exemple pas se mentir
c'est pas le plus simple mais ça lui
fait d'un côté il ya les raisons
artistiques mais faut dire qu'il fait
face à des problèmes financiers suite à
son divorce avec la bmc impact ou si
votre santé et en plus il est également
engagée dans une guerre judiciaire
contre la société tmg et à gérer toute
sa fortune pendant des années et qui
l'accusent de ruines
donc vous mêlez l'artistique avec les
problèmes personnels et professionnels
et bam ça donne ça il ya plein de gens
qui ont des soucis financiers autres et
qui lui fait regarder moi
et et à tous voilà